CASSIE SILVA: Hey
guys, how's it going?
We are the cast
of "Rock of Ages."
So happy to be here
today at Google.
We are over at the Helen Hayes
Theater over at 44th Street.
And we're going to do
a couple more songs
from our show for you today.
Thanks for having us.
[MUSIC - MEDELY
FROM "ROCK OF AGES"]
TONY LEPAGE: It's
totally in good fun,
everybody just has a
really, really great time,
everybody's just having
a ball, having a blast,
but every once in awhile-- I
was on for one of the main parts
one night and sometimes--
What I thought, at the time,
was a t-shirt due to its size
that was thrown at me ended up
being the biggest pair of
panties that I've ever seen
in my entire life--
MALE SPEAKER: A circus
tent of panties.
TONY LEPAGE: I didn't
know what was happening--
CRISTY CANDLER: Still warm.
TONY LEPAGE: Yes.
Not great.
So I pick it up and what I
was thinking, honestly what
I was thinking at
the time was, I
was just like somebody
threw a T-shirt,
I wonder if it says like,
I love "Rock of Ages."
What?
And then everybody was
in on it kind of thing.
So we get some funny
stuff happening.
MICHAEL MINARIK: I had
a gentleman, real quick,
actually when I was on
for one of the characters.
You're dancing at the end of
the show and some guy next to me
is in a suit much like this one.
And it's not the costume
that we have on our show
and I was like, hello.
He goes, how are you doing?
And I see an open
seat down there
and I'm realizing that's
an audience member dancing
with me on my show.
So there are stairs
and I'm just dancing,
pushing him toward the stairs
like, you're doing awesome
and then he goes back down
the stairs and into his seat.
So again, people are just
having honestly the time
of their lives
and they realize--
don't forget that
that's verboten to come
on stage with us.
But it's kind of the most--
I was in the show call "Les
Miserables" and while that
was fun, this is awesome.
So it's just kind
of the best time
every night to do
this show, I think.
ALAN SEALES: Aaron, you're
making your Broadway debut
on the show so congratulations.
Do you feel that your personal
story kind of reflects
your character's story of coming
out of this small little town
and moving to the big city?
AARON C. FINLEY: I'm from a
lot smaller town than Detroit
which is where my
character is from.
I don't think Detroit's all that
small though everybody did move
away, right, when
everything kind of crashed.
I'm from Bozeman,
Montana which is
a really small town,
like 40,000, not tiny.
But yeah, I think in a way.
I mean, Drew is a
young guy who wants
to pursue his dream
of being a rock star.
He moves to LA and he gets
a job in this awesome rock
bar that's famous.
He's just kind of dreaming
of being up on that stage.
I always wanted to sing but
I didn't know about theater
until I was 24 and in college.
For me, theater came along
late and when I found it
I just fell in love right away.
ALAN SEALES: You look like
you're like 24 and a half.
AARON C. FINLEY: Yes
we'll keep it that way.
I have two children so I'm
definitely older than 24.
I didn't start that early.
But my journey is very
similar in that once I
got into theater, I knew that I
wanted to do it at the highest
level and you have to come
to New York to do that.
Because Broadway is what we
look to in the theater world
anyways.
And so I moved out
from Seattle where
I'd been doing
theater professionally
and came out here with just
kind of a hope and a prayer,
and my wife and two little
ones, and four months later
just after auditioning and
showing up every morning
and hitting the pavement
as we say in the business,
I landed "Rock of Ages"
as a lead on Broadway.
And that was kind of
like wow, it can happen.
So yeah, it's been great.
It's been a crazy journey.
ALAN SEALES: You have
super fans, right,
you've got to have people
that come to the show over
and over and over again like
the equivalent of rock groupies
that come to the show.
GENSON BLIMLIN: We have a very
loyal fan base who absolutely
love this show and it's a
pretty remarkable thing.
To the point where most of
them are friends on Facebook
and they follow you on Twitter
and they want to chat it up
and it's great.
The other shows that I've
done, that has never happened.
And it's really interesting.
There's this one guy.
His name is Rob.
Nice guy.
And I know every night
I know he's there
because there's this one
section in the show--
MALE SPEAKER: Remember, this is
going up on YouTube so be nice.
GENSON BLIMLIN: I will.
Of course.
There's nothing
negative about it.
He, without a fail, will be
the one guy in the theater
to respond to this one joke.
I always know if he's there
because it gives me something
to play off of.
And because he
speaks right to me
and I talk right back to him
which the audience thinks
is this amazing spontaneous
moment that happens.
Meanwhile, that guy's
been here 400 times.
It makes me look
really, really good.
One day after the
show he's like I
hope you don't mind if I
do-- I was like, no man.
In a way he's part of
the show in that sense.
And I think that there's a
really cool thing about that.
They're, in a way,
personal with us.
You know, it's cool.
TONY LEPAGE: It's
also amazing how
they'll come to new cast
members' opening nights.
Any time there's a new
cast member, they show up,
and any time somebody's leaving
the show, they'll show up
and they'll be at the stage
door to wish them off.
It's a great group of people.
GENSON BLIMLIN: There's one
girl that's spent, I think,
what are her last three or
four birthdays-- every birthday
she's been there.
And she's seen the show, I'm
not kidding you, 112 times.
Literally she puts it on.
Tonight was my 112th
time at "Rock of Ages."
It was my birthday and
Stacee talked to me
and he threw the panties at
me and it's a whole thing
but she loves it.
ANDREW CALL: That's three
straight months of shows.
If you count that all
the way through, that's
three straight months of
8-a-week shows to come
see a show for five years.
It's impressive.
MICHAEL MINARIK:
We also had a lady
who at the very
beginning, Stacee Jaxx,
a character in the show--
if you haven't seen it--
is the big rock star of
the show and he came out
and this lady asked him
to sign her shoulder.
And he's like, OK.
So he signed her shoulder.
She came back the next day, that
was tattooed in her shoulder
because she loved the
show so much that she
got the tattoo in the shoulder.
GENSON BLIMLIN: Not
the name Stacee Jaxx,
but the guy who plays Stacee
Jaxx who isn't even in the show
anymore.
MICHAEL MINARIK: It's
now in her shoulder.
We started to get tattoos.
We actually have a softball
team and we're not that bad.
We have fans-- two
time champions.
But when you tell your dad you
beat Mary Poppins sometimes
he's not as happy about it.
I'm like, we killed
Mary Poppins.
He's like, what are
you calling me for?
But we have fans that come
to every softball game
and will bake cookies
and stuff for us.
ALAN SEALES: Literal
softball games?
MICHAEL MINARIK: Actually, yeah.
We play the other
Broadway shows,
so it's kind of interesting.
Matthew Broderick
plays sometimes
and it's really an
interesting thing.
Like the Newsies are
there flipping around
in the outfield and stuff.
It's pretty amazing.
ALAN SEALES: You have to
play the game in character.
MICHAEL MINARIK: That
would be awesome.
But our fans--
ANDREW CALL: --in costume.
MICHAEL MINARIK: And we used
to have people do choreography
for us in the front row.
So sometimes again, as
different characters,
you might mess up a little bit
and they'd be doing it right
and so you'd watch them
in the front row doing
your choreography because
they adore the show.
Because of what Tony said, the
joy is just insanely infectious
when you come to the show.
[MUSIC - JOURNEY,
"DON'T STOP BELIEVING"]
TONY LEPAGE: Thank you.